clay aiken
clay aiken america's darling for a brief
period in the early 2000s the runner-up
on american idol clay aiken my
accidental nemesis
from politicon a few years ago clay
aiken is running for congress in north
carolina
he is running in north carolina's sixth
congressional district
he's running after he ran and lost in a
different district in north carolina's
second congressional district but i
think he he believes that he's got a
better shot of winning now in nc six
because of redistricting because it's a
very democrat district now
here is clay aiken's campaign
announcement
for decades north carolina was actually
the progressive beacon in the south we
had the best roads and the best schools
because
back then the loudest voices in our
government were progressives who
actually made sure our stay was always
moving forward
but then things changed and the
progressives lost power and we started
getting backwards ass policies like the
voter suppression bills and the bigoted
bathroom bill
because today it seems like the loudest
voices in north carolina politics are
white nationalists like this guy
my friends i encourage you continue to
make your voice heard because
do we love donald trump
and hateful homophobes like this one
what is the purpose
of homosexuality what does it create
these folks are taking up all the oxygen
in the room and i'm going to tell you i
am
sick of it
and i'll tell you something else as
democrats we have got to get better
about speaking up and using our voices
because those folks ain't quieting down
anytime soon
that's why i'm running for congress and
just think how excited these guys are
going to be when we elect the south's
first gay congressman
so there are some republicans right now
who are friends with clay aiken
not naming any names but there are some
prominent republicans who are friends
with clay aiken who are excited that
he's running he's such a nice guy oh
he's sang that song i don't remember any
of his songs but he sang them nicely and
so isn't it clay aiken's a jerk he's a
freaking jerk and you got to beware the
nice guy in politics okay you got to be
oh i'm just come on i'm just playing i'm
just come on y'all let's come on let's
come together so i was at politicon a
few years ago
and i was debating this guy chris hahn
who i had debated on fox news once and
so we were supposed to have this debate
me and chris hahn except
we didn't end up having a debate because
clay aiken was moderating and clay aiken
took it upon himself to be the actual
opponent in the debate so chris hahn was
just kind of pushed to the side and it
was just me and clay debating each other
the whole time
our people who are marching and shouting
jews will not replace us are they good
people just a yes or no question yes or
no no it's a yesterday question
are people who are marching shouting
jews will not replace nazis
can you say yes or no to this are you
capable of that i don't need to answer a
question because i'm not on the stage no
i did not ask you if nazis were back and
i understand that those are like those
real people who are nazis or okay
that's not
[Applause]
i asked a yes or no question do i know
president trump lie yes or no before
before you before you start since since
clearly the audience thinks i'm biased
we're going to let them ask some
questions
well i may be a hack but i've got
[ __ ] microphone so um
and i just want to say clay you're
probably the worst moderator i've ever
seen in my life asking very dishonest
yes or no questions but anyways that's
perfectly fine clay aiken man he's like
a national president i get food all the
this guy's awful he's awful and he's got
this very disingenuous dated style of
politics well you know y'all um listen i
moved back here i got my voice but it i
don't know to me it reads like something
out of the late 90s or early 2000s
certainly pre-trump pre-social media
authentic politics i'm not sure it's
going to work just a reminder though i
mean the guy is calling a man a white
supremacist or white nationalist based
on absolutely nothing he says that
you're a hateful bigot if you think
dudes shouldn't go into the women's
bathroom and the only flag he flies in
this commercial is not the american flag
but the radical leftist lgbt lmnop flag
this guy is awful he's a jerk beware
beware
the nice guys in
politics hey i'll make this quick ring
the bell please that would be great ring
the bell subscribe get those
notifications
really if you want the notifications
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you